[Music]
hello
and welcome back i've missed you it's
time once again to look over the latest
update to the fortnite battle royale map
and see what has changed and how that
impacts our future
and this week we have story content wow
do me a favor and throw a like to
support this series and think about
subbing too that really helps
and if you'd like to be named in a video
use kodadamaru when you're in the store
if you'd be so kind no pressure this
this is too much begging
for tonight chapter two season four week
eleven already
let's go
[Music]
let's start with the subplot that has
kept us coming back
every single update the bromance
some of you have even suggested calling
this bro watch
i like that right now in game the
traveling duo
are mulling around up at craggy cliffs
this
is a monumental thing to notice they
have backpacks now
let's rewind and tell this story again
because i have a feeling
this may be the last time we see these
guys back when season 4 kicked off we
had previously seen a war between midas
and his two factions
ghost and shadow each week the map
updated in some really great ways to
show
shadow slowly winning the war before
midas's
end game project of a breaking time and
space collapsed
and both factions were reduced to rubble
somehow a single henchman from each side
survived the tsunami and set up home at
retail row and the authority
respectively then two months ago now
they
somehow found each other they both
traveled to the same gas station cafe
and that's when the magic happened even
though if we got too close they became
aggressive
they had a truce moment something
clicked and they realized that there was
more to life than following midas and
his instructions
they became friends two weeks later the
duo now named bill and ted by the psg
community
stayed at the same hotel enjoying pool
parties band rehearsals
and murdering wolverines a fortnight
later the duo began
looking for something first staying at
the dam we were unsure if they were
searching for a new home
or maybe searching for midas and the
answers they deserve
by halloween the duo made it up to
sweaty sands and enjoyed dressing
up and the bromance blossomed even more
getting stronger every single week
this though was also the week that midas
returned to fortnite
but this was not the same midas they
remembered he was undead
we tried to bring them together to see
if there was some sort of bond there
but there isn't midas attempted to
recruit the henchman
into his shadow realm force luckily
though this week
that version of events was rectified as
the duo are still here and they've made
it all the way up to craggy cliffs
but like i mentioned they now have
backpacks and rucksacks on their backs
where is this story going next also
here's the thing for you i'll be giving
out hearts if anyone in the comments can
name the skins those backblings are from
any takers one is quite difficult
so i followed bill and ted and this is
what they do
first the two visit the stores
collecting magazines and snack food
and even though there's no staff there
they still pay
these are quality people next they stock
up on meat
they love a bit of meat just just like
your mum
so sorry i'm so sorry i need to stop
doing that
next day visit the fish sticks
restaurant and fill up before the real
thing to note happens
they look for a perfect boat these guys
are planning to leave us and to compound
all this they choose a tent for their
camping trip
hopefully they don't sail off away never
to be seen again i kinda think they'll
appear on a desert island
and live there forever bill and ted have
become a beacon of leaving the past
behind
and getting on with your life or maybe
these are just silly updates
and i'm reading far too much into this
yeah probably
moving on hot watch over to the
wonderful world of hot watch
and now can you spot the update this
time around
no unless i'm missing something this is
the same hot watch as the one at
halloween
let me know what i'm missing because i'm
getting old now i'm going blind
i need your help oh no i found it the
update is that inside hut watch
the walls have been plastered small
update
completely irrelevant but i like it
[Music]
so now the fog and the undead midas has
left us
we can once again start to concentrate
on the story of the season
i'm sure you've noticed galactus aka the
slowest moving enemy in the history of
mankind
is so close now he's almost close enough
to brofist
by the way if you aim your cursor in his
direction the sound changes to this
ominous drone
it's the sound of inevitability we have
a little law to shine a light on this
recently the mustard we call donald took
part in numerous podcasts
one of which was marvel focused and he
talked about galactus has been on his
way here
for over a year now when the nexus point
was destroyed
by the seven the re-merging of energy
and mass
creating the island for chapter two
alerted galactus
who has been on his way here ever since
he wants the
power of the nexus luckily his herald
thor
is a little quicker at travelling and he
got here to help us survive
but that's when the memory issues and
lack of speech
affected the blonde bombshell luckily he
summoned heroes to assist us
including tony stark have you kept an
eye on his biome
since his arrival tony has been
constructing a battle bus to do battle
with the flying planet eater
each week his plans evolve from a simple
blueprint on a board to the appearance
of a garage to the slow
battle bus upgrades to this point right
now his designs
are fully rolled out three battle buses
are found on the map right now with
stark upgrades
plus the one we use in game and here's
the point to note
this strange glow on top of the bus what
is this object here
and what the heck does it do any
intergalactic
technicians in the house what the heck
is stark built
we are traveling towards a huge in-game
event but i still can't piece it
together yet
i do think thorn needs to call for more
support and looking at the war table
right now
he's thinking about it as we speak but
we can speak
they can't speak because speaking in
fortnite is not a thing
i'm so confused right now fortnite is
great
[Music]
now that the halloween festivities have
left us let's check on things that have
changed
firstly midas and his cronies have gone
back to the shadow realm and sadly
his golden chair has gone too i kind of
hoped this thing would stick around
longer and become
story law related but it looks like it's
solely here for halloween so maybe we'll
see it next year
this also means the authority is back
but the destruction has remained
including the loss of brutus's shrine oh
but in fact remember midas is coming
back again next week
in the form of a dc shapeshifter called
rex
could this impact the story with dc and
marvel teaming up
over at the newly built halloween
superstar over by holly hedges
it has once again closed down and it's
been abandoned
nothing remains inside except a few
boxes and neglected gear
if the store sticks around i think we
can all agree that this will become
another festive store a home for mariah
carey and those people who like
christmas songs
a little bit too much you know who you
are
and an update i totally missed last time
and hundreds of you put
me straight thank you so much when i saw
the update to camp cod
i totally missed the greatest easter egg
ever in the new barn
was a covered vehicle when struck it
made a strange noise
a noise only ghostbuster fans would
recognize
hidden under that cover is ecto-1 the
hearse
the ghostbusters use in the movies and
the cartoons and all the other things
they're in
then the skins released too perfect for
catching the shadow undead during
halloween
well played if you saw this update and
thank you for letting me know
in a weird update there is now only one
flaw on the gas station at sweaty sands
i have no idea why
and finally another story has reached a
conclusion seemingly
the story of the genome-hating cyborg
you guys named the genominator
this week get your butt down to slurpee
to see what happened to him
he is deaded two months back we saw a
lovable slurp juice salesman come to
town and within moments of his arrival
he was taken out by the nominator the
villain and his bots began placing
explosives on sacred slurp juice barrels
but thankfully we all disarmed the bombs
before the gnome community was alerted
we also found the villain's secret base
and foiled his next plan
a plan to poison the slurp juice factory
for some reason
we cleansed the bats by jumping in them
which is
crazy to me we then confronted the
nominator he attempted to use a rocket
pack to escape
but crashed and now this week his
resting place
is honored we can even pay our respects
for a challenge
the tea bagging here is is optional is
anybody here on keyboard and mouse
i know this depends on key bindings but
i really hope it says press
f to pay respects that would be too
perfect
so that's the update this time around
next week i plan to make a story update
video as donald mustard has given away
lots of plot points i want to put into
one big story video
on screen now are the legends roll call
the names of the people who use my code
to buy something in the store
and then send me a twitter dm to flex
their mighty purchases
like always thank you so much i truly
appreciate what you do for me so that's
it what did i miss
let me know if there's anything i missed
and i'll add it next time
i'm adam from playstation grenade you're
awesome thanks for staying till the end
here have a free dad joke i'm currently
reading a book about anti-gravity
it's impossible to put down that's so
bad
so bad let me try again let me try again
um what has two bottoms
and murders people an assassin
assassin you get it ass ass
okay i'm going bye